hey everyone hey and welcome back to yet
another episode of watching the Watchmen
this is a regular podcast in which
myself my co-hosts are going through
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons Watchmen we
are also in the unenviable position of
looking into Doomsday Clock which is the
official tie-in sequel to Watchmen and
this issue in particular very much
fills in a few blanks and you know Texas
a few places that maybe you wouldn't
have expected so as ever we're gonna be
going through going in-depth going you
know not necessarily panel by panel but
we're gonna be here putting a bit of a
critical magnifying glass on this thing
please get in touch to the show watching
The Watchmen product.you Montcalm
haven't got any emails to read out this
episode unfortunately no one really
allows us but hopefully if we play here
you can give us some feedback on issue 4
of Doomsday Clock and if you eight I
believe of Watchmen they're on at the
moment but anything you've got to say
about anything comic wise he's always
greatly appreciated it's never myself
I'm always with death death how's it
going young men are you listening to me
you know like I start every episode with
a song to get the listeners hyped a bit
in nostalgic a bit like this comic book
Tom yeah yeah really you know we've been
a bit sly on on the Doomsday Clock
series so far but I've always said and
you can listen the episodes that things
tend to get good around episode 4 or
issue 4 so we're getting in an issue for
right now yeah yeah when we begin with
some pancakes which I mean I have been
critical you know I've been the more
critical of the duo here I have to say
and I've appreciated more and more every
issue Gary Frank is an amazing
illustrator
he is truly brilliant and those pancakes
are amazing on the cover what brilliant
drawing then the best pancakes I've ever
seen in my life I just want to eat them
yeah and I loved the way that he's
managed to incorporate the Rorschach
masks into them you know the pancakes
from I think issue 2 was it were quite a
big thing yeah yeah with the Rorschach
eating them so it's good that you know
Rorschach's embedded in these pancakes
right now and it's a really good cover
and we're um you know the pancakes lead
us into the Arkham Asylum
and similar you know I was thinking a
lot about parallels when I was doing my
notes and it's interesting you mentioned
issue four because the issue for of
Watchmen I think we both said it was or
maybe our favorite issue it's certainly
my favorite issue
yeah the dr. Manhattan origin you know
with the photograph on the cover a
watchmaker I believe it's called and you
know that's all about parallel timelines
and things reflecting each other and we
kind of have this throughout the issue
don't we with regi year Arkham and
Reggie and Fitzgerald yeah I did find it
quite difficult to differentiate from
different time zones at some points and
but we'll go more into that later when
they kind of transfer into it I do like
how there's this repetition of the lunch
line and I loved seeing zebra man he's a
very old-school Batman villain right and
it's just nice that they kind of tie
this in throughout the issue they do
mention Tweedledee and Tweedledum they
also you can see Maxie Zeus is standing
behind zebra man there there's also the
ventriloquist and Waylon Jones who's
Killer Croc his name appears in it and
throughout this kind of this reference
to the overall DC Network and bigger
universe so it is it is quite nice that
they've kind of tied this all together
yeah yeah because I guess Reggie is now
translated transplanted in the DC you
know extend universe so they're kind of
and it's you know I knew this guy was
someone III Percy didn't know whose
every man was zebra man I mean he's just
a minor sort of 50s cuz it you know I
love like you know I love that comic
books although about Grant Morrison and
Alan Moore all these people they go back
into the 50s archive when people were
literally coming up with zebra man what
the [ __ ] is called zebra man and making
him something interesting yeah and it's
all became like almost a motif recently
to reinvent the older Batman villains
especially em kite man was like really
really obscure villain and Tom King's
recently just did a whole arc with him
and it was really nice like they did an
origin story forum like you kind of
reminisce as over his dying son
and they used to run and do kites
together and he makes this costume the
kind of almost as sort of a hem well
just to reminisce over the fun that he
had with his son sort of like it you
know a nice reminder I'm trying to think
of the word tomboy yeah it's very
sentimental and it's great that they are
kind of bringing back these older
villains because the [ __ ] ruined most
of the new ones Tom three Joker's what
the hell are they talking about what's
happening yeah well I mean that is
what's happening and yeah it's a shame
it's a shame and yeah it's um it's nice
maybe we don't need so many on Margie's
two Watchmen for out and obviously this
longer thing he's a classic Watchmen
moment so I don't mind them doing this
and you know him seeing the mushroom
cloud in his forehead it's cry it's kind
of nice I don't I don't think I think I
think one of my problems really
we've Jeff Jones and I have a lot of
problems with Jeff Jones is that it's
not the most graceful storytelling we'll
get on to the puzzle pieces later which
here fella out a lot but you know I've
got to say all in all I did mostly enjoy
this issue and this issue definitely has
a moment that is my favorite moment so
far of Doomsday Clock Oh
lilulu yeah actually enjoyed an issue
cooked on my car I don't enjoy this
issue but there's a moment thought that
there's a moment actually really quite
moved me and I thought it was quite
brilliant but you know we get to that
moment a lot of people saying def a lot
of reviews saying especially that may be
one of the flaws of this issue is it
doesn't really take the plot anywhere
it's essentially a Reggie Rorschach
origin story well yeah I mean sort of
agree with that but I don't really think
it needs to be honest Reggie I kind of
do find it quite difficult to get beyond
him like yes literally just a carbon
copy of the old one in pretty much every
way other than skin tone and in past
episodes I've sort of talked about how
the race swap sort of cheapens black
characters in a way because it doesn't
really feel like Jones could be bothered
to invent a new black character to
really stand as a pinnacle the black
heroes so instead he's just kind of
swapped them out whilst we do learn his
backstory and to me it's not as
empowering because he has to take up so
one else's manhole to Benoist and
watching them almost as a washed down
version of the original just makes me
think that it's the same way that John's
is very derivative of more but it's
without the spark that Moore had in the
same way that Reggie is sort of
Rorschach but without the spark that the
original had and there's some pages in
that this book that our panel for panel
recreations yeah and it just sort of
like member Barry's the comic book for
me there I mean is it it definitely is
the best like issue and just this
setting itself it's always nice to kind
of as a psychological study to put
heroes in in an insane asylum and to
just kind of question you know are they
fit with the inmates do they fit in
there and you know what I'm you told you
just it just makes me a bit nervous it's
like are we gonna have is it gonna be
like Star Wars where it's just so much
things are Marg and they can't break
away you know what I mean is it gonna
end with Superman battling a big squid
monster like yeah these things sort of
because it probably is like there
probably is gonna be some sort of giant
New York psychic event and all that
stuff and like it's a fun idea to think
okay let's put an interesting writer in
The Watchmen universe see what he does
but unfortunately more is like you say
he's just sorry not more I mean geoff
johns is just sort of tracing over more
and it's the subtlety that i like so I
like the fact that we're now in the DC
Universe and we can sort of appreciate
what was happening at this time so I
guess when Reggie was young is kind of
tied to the early letters of byron at
the end so the sort of 70s era sort of
thing and I like that we hear about you
know dr. Manhattan's entrance into
Vietnam and this sort of stuff and when
we have the apartment where Reggie's
watching the TV and you look at this the
cityscape behind him
that the sort of dome structures that
you see in the back of this world and
you know yeah it's very attentive and
what did you think about this
quote-unquote
reveal that Reggie's Malcolm's son well
a guy a right didn't we yeah like we did
say on one episode but then again it
wasn't very hard considering there's
only
one black character and all the Watchmen
you know I mean it was exactly well
hidden but I do quite like how they they
tied into that I feels fitting that the
son of the doctor obsessed with
Rorschach will become him and and we
watch as he grows up in the Watchmen
universe now what's most interesting to
me is that you get to see the Watchmen
world from the perspective of a normal
person yes um and you know it he's shy
and he's a bit of a loser and similar to
though the characters in Watchmen he's
not exactly archetypical hero he isn't a
Superman he's not a Batman you've got
floors he's not a cool guy
he saw the loser um and it's just nice
watching him traverse through this
universe I absolutely love when he
escapes the asylum and just because of
the frantic feel that there is and it's
just there's an it's nice back story
flash back story flashing out without
ruining the Canon yeah yeah definitely I
think there's a few moments that we'll
get to that I think are a little bit
padded out in terms of that in terms of
their sort of you know their boxing and
there's a bit there's not that much
necessarily happening but I like the
fact that you know I always liked it in
movies when you see scenes from
different perspectives and you get to
appreciate a little bit more detail like
you know slide here or whatever so you
know we see Reggie what just before we
get to him at college is that mr. freeze
in in the cryo chamber yeah yeah it is
yeah so that's in Arkham Asylum I'm just
to ground it in there where sometimes
they don't really hint exactly at what
time period it is and you also get the
mosquito flying into the buzz light
there is it called the buzz light get
the zapper I don't want to tell you time
for I know I know what you mean yeah
yeah we all we all know what you mean
and you know we get sort of close ups
from Reggie while he was blood on his
mouth spitting out zebra man's fresh
yeah we're doing it's quite cool
actually you know I I like that movement
so we get to see in terms of the angles
from a different angle
we get to see Hector Godfrey's interview
which we saw you know and and this is at
now in Reggie's room where his roommates
are kissing and you know the very sort
of did you watch Watchmen sort of panel
where it has the Hashima lovers and him
in the middle
which say again I don't mind I'll you
know and we get the the sort of the
interview as well where Malcolm's
outside the penitentiary and being so
open to as well and it's you know I've
compared it side-by-side to the original
issues and it's recreated well it's
recreated very faithfully death yeah
it's two days in this entire book is a
nice faithful recreation but it doesn't
feel like it has enough of its own
uniqueness to kind of impress me no and
we get a lot of Reggie I mean the
problem is that I think it would have it
would have been better if there would
have been one or two subplots like just
let us know where marionette is just let
us know what else he's doing you know
anybody yeah Reggie yeah which was a
staple of the original Watchmen like
boom you you did have a Rorschach origin
story issue and then a dr. Manhattan one
but yeah I do get what you mean there's
a lot of questions still going on
whereas in the original Watchmen I don't
think if you were reading it there would
have been that many questions you just
kind of engrossed in the world and
watching it play out where is this you
just always asking like well who's this
character what's gonna happen there I
mean we need to find out what happened
to Oz Newman Dyess in the comedian and
there's just so many unanswered things i
Superman appear at the end of issue one
and he's not been back in since yeah so
the dream yes it's kind of hard to get
attached to the characters when they're
so sparse I think yeah yeah and but I do
like that there's little flashes of The
Watchmen universe for example in the
psychiatrist's head you see the big
alien eye is sort of having flashes of
this horrendous world that is left
behind that apparently drove everyone
mad yeah yeah and we you know we see
again more scenes with different
perspectives
the scene where Malcolm's staying up
light was coffee and something we
pointed out which is testament to how
you can rewatch him in a billion times
and still see new stuff where he let
where he leaves his pen on the jatta and
it calls as the Rorschach which again
I'm just sort of marveling at
interesting as well just in terms of the
comic in terms of the Watchmen comic the
scene that proceeds that exactly
perceives the coffee scene is the
queuing scene in the prison where when
Walter sort of douses that
with that hot fat and you know we see
sort of Reggie's mother putting on a
brave face of somewhat Gloria and him
working with the with the with his mug
and with his notes and then what I'd
like is and what I think is quite
convincing as character motivation we
learn why Reggie so messed up it's been
sort of hinted at before that he you
know survived this psychic assault which
you can only imagine it killed three
million people must have been
devastating to see yeah I never actually
thought about like that to be honest
my memory of Watchmen even though how
massively prefer the book always tends
to be of the film and that was just a
bomb going off but I forgot there was a
psychic attack involved in it so yeah it
is quite nice that there's kind of this
madness and a lot of the pages are very
frantic and engaging and you can sort of
perfectly picture what's going on in his
mind and it reminds me a lot of Rambo
first blood and when the horror kind of
drives you into berserk mode and it's
nice that the pages have this feeling to
it and just as the character does but
it's still when he runs up to the roof
and meets Mothman I did think this was
Arkham Asylum still yeah so it is quite
difficult to kind of you see originally
I thought was Killer Moth on the roof
and it was until he says that it's
Mothman Leia that was kind of like
alright this is a different time period
then yeah yeah exactly yeah it's
slightly confusing that they they live
these look um but you know going going
forward into the the interview then
which we learn is that Bruce as the
guise of the therapist um it might be
yeah I think lately you see is mask yeah
I think so yeah I was I was pretty
certain he was well yeah it is a little
bit I don't think it's told brilliantly
I think like you say with the mouth
stuff it's not quite clear where we are
like he's wearing orange he's wearing
green etc but it years and I don't know
it's hard for them to do because it's a
comic book it's just drawings it's
harder to signal it but I think it
could've been something a bit more clear
here yeah well Gibbons managed
- fine yeah there's this massive time
jumps across like 60 years in Watchmen
but the tent I sort of lead into it for
example when they're looking at the
photograph of the Minutemen in Watchmen
you then have the flash which then
transforms into the the camera and it
takes you back to when the photo was
being taken whereas this is literally
just he's running down one corridor in
the DC Universe and then the next panel
he's running down the corridor in the
Watchmen universe and there's no kind of
differentiation between the two hem and
it just becomes a bit convoluted because
of it
yeah yeah it does it certainly does and
we I like I like the eye opening through
his forehead I thought that was pretty
cool actually
I enjoy that and it's like you say the
flash we have similar movements here
narrative lis of him sort of screaming
and him being saved pulled out of a car
in the aftermath and we get to sort of
see kind of what New York would have
been like after this or whatever sort of
city trying to be and sort of moving
forward but here's my problem because I
I do like the roof scene I think I think
there's a lot of Majesty here I think
it's really well drawn you really get
the sense of who this character is and
you know I always remember I think it's
Sally
um who's sort of chronicling all the
Minutemen and what happened but I always
remember she says that Byron Lewis the
mothman's in a bughouse in Maine yeah
and you know that always stuck to me for
some reason and he was this sort of kind
of similar to night owl this archetype
who has money and wants to be a hero but
mentally Mothman clearly wasn't you know
cut out for it and well that's why he's
here yeah definitely and it is night
that they kind of resurrect this
character because he is sort of one of
the unanswered questions in Watchmen um
kind of like what happened to the
original Minutemen and what you do get
minor bits of exposition in the original
book that kind of tell you what happened
it's nice to actually see one of these
characters living and breathing and and
he's it's really I think he's my
favorite character in the book so far
he's sort of the hero and he seems like
a really nice guys quite charming I
really warmed him over everyone else in
the book
and I think it's just cuz he's sort of
using his powers to do simple things to
make people happy and like a 1-point he
gets Reggie's dad's belongings and it's
just little comforts that he's going to
a lot of trouble for but it makes the
character endearing and throughout this
we kind of see him become a mentor and
he teaches Reggie how to fight I'm using
the other mini men's moves but the way
that he dies is terrible yeah but other
than that I thought it was good yeah
okay
okay I love I love the way kind of
glides off into the night yes yes very
memorable and graceful and there's sort
of a deeper meaning to it as well and if
you visualize something you can do it
it's this Tesla og ideology and it's
great to see a silhouette just take off
into the night I agree I agree it feels
you wonder when you see it happen I
think Knoll Edmunds as well has that
philosophy of visualization so it's yeah
it's slightly questionable but I love
the fact that when he jumps off there's
multiple things going in my head
because when he jumps up like you saw
see your silhouette here in your case
you know classic cape sort of hero but
then you see that it's like patched
together Asylum boards and he asks later
for like spare Springs
you know he's nude as well yeah you you
you respect what's going on I love the
trees as well underneath him I just
think it's a nice sort of touch they
seem too similar to him and you know
barren of leaves and him walking away
and you know Reiki feels hope at last
and I like that yet that in the so you
have the panel's going back and forth
between him beating off into the
distance and Reggie watching and in the
second panel you see the sort of bold
orderlies head just above it yeah all
the encroach there um I think I think
it's a great sequence I've got to give
laud its yeah and it's good that he's
kind of Jones's embodied hope once more
in these books they got it so greatly in
dark that it's just nice to see like a
shining ray what hero should be and
because these are all really complicated
characters but that's just someone who's
very simple out there he's just I can
fly and he just believes it and he flies
off into the night and it ties in with
the title as well and the walk on water
one which is sort of that miracles can
happen if you believe in them
so this is quite poetic it is it is and
you know he sort of learns he has to
play the game to a certain extent you
know realizing that visualization is the
key and quite quite actually like when
you see his parents as the Rorschach
pattern I don't know if you yes that
personally but it's quite effective as a
as a motif yeah definitely
and it's that repetition of you know the
Rorschach the hints and the imagery kind
of repeating through the book um
Rorschach's mask has sort of always been
a symbol within Watchmen and it's nice
that it's slowly becoming engrossed with
in this universe once more and you know
we learned that this is a man who just
flies to a diner to get you know eggs on
sourdough it's a little bit I'm not one
of these people who points out like oh
that's unbelievable in a film whatever I
always hate that sort of thinking but
it's crazy how much this guy could get
away and fly and not get held down I
guess he never got caught much is the
inference but yeah it just lives a
simple life doesn't he like people
aren't probably putting themselves out
there um to like track them down
massively that they're not probably know
he's a nice guy so he's not a massive
threat and he just wants to fly around
he's just going around creating miracles
Tom yeah maybe maybe one day you'll land
on this podcast and we'll get more than
ten listeners it'll be a miracle and you
know the world buildings nice here we
get a lot of VTS of Ozymandias we
learned that a historic meeting between
Nixon and Gorbachev went down at Veidt
enterprises which it was quite q that
was quite nice and the idea of you know
vy in this sort of most messianic
complex after the attack of c no one's
aware of this at that time so which is
interesting actually because if you
think of the time line I never hear a
mention of the journal here do you which
nobody would unravel everything and that
happened at the same time as Watchmen
ends maybe that was the catalyst but it
seems like Veidt getting exposed is just
I I don't know he just sort of gets
found out yeah it just seems to be part
of this world but
I'll go into it more in the other issues
but yeah it just kind of seems whoops I
got found out guys yeah I don't know if
it's because other people start getting
murdered or what but I don't hurry don't
know I don't know what guys Martha my
just take a little stroll into a fire
well know what the hell's going on Tom
you know you know where I mentioned
earlier the what my favorite thing was
the book was spoilers
it is Mothman going into the fire I know
you don't like that thing I thought it
was quite beautiful and like I know what
you mean narrative Lee it doesn't really
make sense that you used two signs to
kill himself but I think as a sort of
Moffat to the flame aesthetic Wow so
intelligent yes so much subtext I mean
what is it just that he can't but I mean
he it's like what you can't live a life
outside of you know wherever he is but
hasn't you been going out constantly
every night I don't really yeah I guess
I don't know what to I don't know what
he's doing but as we had you know in the
abyss gazes also Malcolm means Rorschach
e we have Reggie being Bruce and what is
this thinking of Bruce to interview
Reggie in Arkham why wouldn't he just
capture him in the Batcave and question
him there I don't know and they do kind
of hang a lantern on it later and that's
a phrase Tom when you do something
stupid but you say it's stupid
immediately after so they do it all the
time in movies and whether they do
something stupid and they go well that
was it why didn't you just do this and
it makes they're trying to get the
audience to kind of side with them and
realize oh yeah
yeah you should have done that but they
know it in the same way that Alfred's
like yeah you do realize this guy knows
a lot about us so maybe that's why I
went into Arkham because you kind of
realized they are [ __ ] I've let this guy
in a place with all my worst villains
and he knows from who I am in real life
yeah so I don't know no no there's a few
things here that you just self have to
brush off it's not got the sort of
mechanic
accuracy of more where everything
balances and make sense yeah it's got a
sort of gone the right and here we see
Reggie moved Afton after the therapists
meeting and we see a Jane Doe looking on
from the bars um some people were saying
this was a character that I'm not
familiar with in DC Lord Jupiter girl
okay now that she must be an old one as
well yeah I'll talk heard her name um
but I don't know for definite I'll just
quickly google it Tom make it some way
I'm really clever though Saturn girls
are excuse me Saturn not really no
apparently oh wait I mean she is Thomas
is a notable serial killer who would
observe and get to know people then kill
them and take their identities I
actually do remember her and she was in
a Harvey Bullock eccentric Detective
Comics I am from the new 52 and
basically Harvey Bullock fell in love
with this woman and but she was just
using someone else's identity and then
she was gonna use his identity in you
know Tom you know how it goes yeah yeah
if you kill Batman you become Batman
right right yeah the sort of argument in
this review was like she's someone who
also I've like telepathy powers and now
you just read note a reveal oh yeah I
checked the reviews for studiously to
see what people think and most people
have been pretty positive you know a lot
of people have sort of been middling to
bad but we hear sort of you know we
learn about this and it's quick I like
how Reggie calls the therapist bloated
an arrogant which I'm pretty sure is
word-for-word how Rorschach Dean Malcolm
as well so you know there's lots of sort
of hard stuff we get the picture of the
chameleon smashed we get to see all the
old guys as well we get to see Mothman
who his wingspan is sort of behind
dollar bill and silhouette which is
really nice as well and we have a
close-up on comedian I'm sure we're
gonna see more yeah shut up for a second
you know I noticed a continuity error
there because I'm sure that the
minutemen photograph with the comedian
on was black and white right I'm sure
it's black and white
okay and I've just I'm gonna cook it is
it's bloody black and white Tom Wow
so Jones is a hack do not read this book
unsubscribe from this podcast I don't
want anything more to do with it that is
a bit of a blooper yes because I read it
and I thought I'm sure that's black and
white yeah okay well I mean look Danza
let's end it they're not reading any
more of this [ __ ] um mothman you know he
could just gather things we need a way
narrative Lee for Reggie to sort of
learn of Rorschach and yeah I'm familiar
with him so yeah what the hell Mothman
come Floyd to Reggie's house and get
everything it's all there it's you know
I'm just I'm just gonna not question
that that's fine and we get the dad mug
as well I can't deal with the puzzle
though deaf I can't deal with them
seeing some face okay the fight of peace
it's just it's too it's too Geoff Johns
II for me
but it was right in front of em the
whole time but you loved the moth to the
flame why did you love a guy walking
into a fire to kill himself but you
don't love their little it was right in
front of the finally putting the pieces
together Tom them yeah in the pieces
together
yeah but yes in Moore's hands when he
smashes the mug like I could argue when
he smashes the mug it's giving you ad
rather than BC so it's like I knew but
but that that is Troy as [ __ ] like with
more than be something cool there but no
we have this sort of bully guy who works
in there and you know it's nice to see
that the Byron and Reggie have this or
relationship and I like the fact that
Jon's has gone back into the minutemen
arguably mothman's the only person he
really could have used because I'm
pretty sure silhouette was dead and but
yeah this was missing and a dollar bill
gets killed at a bank as well so I'm
pretty sure this was the only guy who
could have actually used um I think
right more he hadn't revealed the
mystery already and so Watchmen is very
much a book when you read it the second
time you start to see all the pieces
fall into place whereas the pieces of
the jigsaw Tom see what I did there are
already in place like we know Veidt is
the killer
was back in the day more would have done
it in issue one or something and they're
not issue twelve you get the reveal at
he's the kill any go but you got all
while he was laying out like this
whereas more errands are sort of laying
out but we already have the answers so
it doesn't seem as clever and I also
think you just a bit of a hater Tom I'm
a I'm afraid it was right in front of us
the whole time just a bit like I don't
know I I come to graphic novels and
comic books for sophistication in
storylines and they're written for
children yeah well I mean I'm just I'm
not really a fan of mr. ma [ __ ] like
I'm not a fan of The Karate Kid nests of
him training him to be a crime I mean
it's fine but it's like Mothman to me
was always this kind of mentally
unstable
you know Icarus who just ya rabb to fly
not someone who could necessarily train
someone but buddy but it's fine again we
need an origin story and it does his job
yeah no I like it
Tom I do like the the mentor training
the the student I've always liked that
motif and I think it's quite nice yay so
he says he's not a good fighter himself
but he you studied the other Minutemen
and sort of know some moves from them so
that's quite nice yeah I also like how
they mentioned Robert Redford's well
they say President Redford which yeah
but don't trust him cuz he controlled
the Winter Soldier Tom you know when a
soldier movie you know big big Robbie
Redford well yeah
I've not seen much of the MCU I know you
quite the family oh sure Tom I'm not
gonna see your video war Wow I'm taking
a stand
you can have it well why you spoiling
you're spoiling it for yourself Tom it's
like a good movie I'm just saying saying
I'm not gonna eat this beautiful dinner
I'm gonna have this bit of cheese then
the cheese's obviously Doomsday Clock
for which is spending all your time
focusing on just get into the MCU Tom
use the patreon money to buy yourself
some bloody blu-rays it's 2 for 15 right
now so bad that's not bad
you know again it's something knowing
the history like you say I'm not a fan
of the train images but I like that all
the names are named here old an eye out
Woody Justice Mothman that sort of stuff
and you know I guess it makes sense that
Reggie eventually adopts this Rorschach
thing and it's not an angle that they
really speak about in the book but it's
kind of how I read it that you know
Reggie loved his father and him and
Rorschach Malcolm a friend yeah we're
friends so he's trying to kind of be
that surrogate yeah no I think it's
quite nice I can see this happening in
real life where the Sun doesn't really
want it like following the footsteps of
the father but then the father passes
away and he sort of owes it to his
legacy to carry on his work and so it's
quite nice and I also like how they hint
that as human die is killed the original
Silk Spectre yes and it's quite
intriguing that yeah that did like that
yeah she was an old bloke blow it [ __ ]
wasn't she Tom apparently so apparently
so and you know he gets shown a
Rorschach card Reggie in a sort of later
test says that you know he sees
Rorschach we learn about veidt's that
the conspiracies the New York Massacre
someone who kind of looks a bit like a
dilapidated John Oliver at the right of
that panel we sort of looking forward
and you know we and and you know Reggie
has is his motive now you know he has
someone you know in effect killed his
parents you always need a sort of killed
parents angle which if the comic books
isn't it yeah apparently that's a DC
thing apparently they sort of pioneered
that we've Batman and other people and
Marvel sort of you know stole it away
from them and stuff like that but and I
like the Mothman is realistic you know
he says what he didn't do it and I guess
Mothman would have been in the bughouse
before Ozzie became popular I guess
those timelines would have so maybe they
wouldn't have met but yeah we get we get
some nice paneling here and I agree what
you're saying there is a frantic nature
everyone leaving and we see when he
likes the matchbook it's the Ganga diner
you know that we've seen in hundreds of
things in Watchmen before which
generally nice you should buy a new era
cup with
gunga diner on and this is what back
when I was massively into like fit caps
and stuff yeah and it was about fifty
pound and I was like do I buy it but you
know it was pretty it look like I was
just walking around advertising some
diner Tom yeah so I didn't end up buying
it in the end that's too abstract it's
too abstract yeah I've just I've just
looked on images yeah holy [ __ ] that's
cool though existed yeah yes so me and
you we can go Harper's on it Tom and you
can wear on in Monday Tuesday Wednesday
now where the rest of the time so you
read yeah the this this Byron descending
into the fire of his paper wings this
does nothing for you no I know it
obviously meant to be very reminiscent
of Rorschach being born and or when he
was watching the fire and yeah yeah that
was a lot more atmospheric I thought
yeah after they cut that dog's head open
Tom yeah your favorite bit of that book
wasn't it yeah and so Reggie dies in the
asylum in Rorschach's reborn from the
fire it's like a phoenix tom mmm they
bloody phoenix put that in your essay
but that in your review that you're
reading from online and it's not a you
know it's not a john story if we don't
get long narration here to sort of fill
in the missing plot points and i do like
the fact that he gets a boarding pass to
on the percy bysshe which is you know
the famed romantic poet who wrote the
poem Ozymandias and four things there
yes nice nice little reference there and
he seems to have some sort of clipping
that tells you where Ozzy mundos lives I
don't know why that was in the newspaper
but that was there and you know he sort
of you know out of the fire into the ice
certain thing and we see the the thing
cracking across the ice smiled at me
and I guess Reggie sort of the ideology
of Rorschach the him is a bit different
to Walter as a whole it's a bit more
gray thing isn't it rather than black
and white yeah definitely it's sort of
this often happens when someone else
takes up the mantle a sort of
through the original ideas and sort of
take them in their own direction which
is sort of what John's is doing overall
um but I think it is a nice evolution of
the character what would happen if
someone else decided to become Rorschach
I really like the journey through the
snow I really sort of loved that since
like Batman Begins yeah which is a sort
of another callback and I think the the
mentor thing in this and the sort of
walking through the snow is very Batman
Begins
um and I often think when I'm walking
through the snow of Batman Begins you
just gotta power through it and get
there and then we finally get to the
prize and that little pyramid tent
evolves into Karnak right yes and then
he's sort of it kind of Bubastis esque
like yeah you know in the noises that
they make and yeah Rorschach or I should
I say Reggie is going through here and
it's kind of cool to see Roy I can like
a duffle coat as well rather than a hat
yeah it's kind of a modern reinvention
and osmond eyes being the generic evil
genius that he is has his back turn sat
in front of his evil plans right [ __ ]
idiot this bit for me they sort of it
did make me cringe a little bit they
find parity a little too quickly and I
know they know it's a comic book and
it's got 26 pages and we need to move
things along but you know Rorschach's
angry he says sorry they become friends
yeah yeah I don't know he's literally
been walking miles and miles and miles
go like this he's been doing I eat lots
of he's lost boy when he does he's
mental over this and yeah yes yeah let's
let's go I guess even though it's not
like Ozzie says I have a plan it's like
let's just sort of head off here and
yeah they sort of team and like that's
what I didn't find satisfying really
because I remember a speaker notes in
the first issue like why he's always
working together what's gonna happen
here and I think in terms of our
Rorschach's origin it is quite fine
like it's fine like Reggie becomes
Rorschach I understand how that happens
but these two guys teaming up I just I
don't know it doesn't doesn't sit well
for me death yeah I mean I do kind of
see what you say but I do like I'm gonna
say something that you're probably gonna
block me on every social media platform
right now but I think John's does better
with Ozymandias than more did Wow yeah I
just think this moment way sort of
breaks down and realizes that he's a
monster
I did actually quite enjoy and which is
more than more did for him he was very
sort of the villain em and you couldn't
really see things from his point of view
and whereas here he's just kind of like
yeah man a [ __ ] up yeah oh yeah no
bother me I know I've just walked 50
miles in minus 20 weather but yeah no
bother but this to be let's be friends
yeah but Ozzie Ozzie in Watchmen lived
without consequence whereas I don't know
how long this is after what's happened
but he just never what you know he was
good he was very ignorant in that regard
really he saw it as the Gordian knot as
they say you know something you could
just divide and and solve it but you
know with all his TV screens and you
know because I mean doesn't Watchmen end
with him talking to dr. Manhattan and
being like you know what yeah he's on
nothing ever ends and then he sort of
goes into some other never realm and
stuff like that again you know we
haven't really been speaking too much
about the are here that are is fantastic
you know I think yeah Dave Gibbons is
one of those eyes that does faces does
expression so well and I think Frank's
rises to the plate here yeah definitely
it's really good art and I've sort of
flicked through the pages of before
Watchmen and kind of compared them but I
do think and barley Bermejo
who's probably my favorite comic book
artist Frank does a really good job with
this and it's probably the best art
Watchmen related other than Big Boi late
I think definitely yeah the partnership
begins really and then we go back into
into Arkham we have a we're all mad here
which is quite nice
you know of Alice reference and then we
have our our girl here on Saturn girl
and is this is this is dr. Manhattan
right in some sort of form helping him
out maybe I really don't know yeah it's
not it's not clear is I don't blue light
yeah I took the blue light and I guess
because right at the end we see the
photo go in front of the frame of him
and Janey
so I assume that was white which again
to me it's like we had the smiley button
drop in on chameleons and he washes
ashore it's like we don't need these
things it's like yeah if you're waiting
they seemed no Watchmen it's just been
he's been at the comic book shop man
just bought loads of Watchmen
paraphernalia and it's just walking
around falling out of his pockets flying
around like I need explanation for these
John's because if this is just you
making the read of realize what's going
on then I'm not game I'm not yelling
John but yeah and then and then we also
have them leaving and then that's all
Rorschach was no compromises but it
turns out here's the first opportunity
yes and we see the fastest or some sort
of Bubastis clone in a small little case
which you know we see in other Doomsday
Clock issues as well and then we have
the you know the mask which I always
read is that was what Batman was doing
but I've not really know Batman to pawn
a mask and pretend to be a therapist
it's all very on Batman oh it does he'd
always goes into this guy's tom matches
matches Malone is like my favorite
disguise over me and my friend and he
was a massive Batman fan and we see like
always to just be sitting there like oh
hey matches hey guys what's up so what's
happening at the docks tonight okay
matches I tell you my plan just
basically it was just a way for Batman
to kind of infiltrate gangs and stuff
but he's got loads of different
disguises and the Dark Knight Returns
he's he's got a famous one though he's
like some old policeman and he's also
got this weird
I don't like old woman disguise but it's
drawn so weird that it's like crazy and
it really like the first time I read it
I would say what the [ __ ] is this but
d-does go out and miss disguises he's a
master of disguise someone's a Tom yeah
yeah and it from Alfred
because Alfred was very theatrical in
his youth a ram and he sort of learned
how it do disguises from him yeah and I
mean we get very little from these two
guys but yeah basically you know Alfred
say he knows too much and and we don't
know enough but you know he doesn't I
mean he knows a little bit and he sort
of he knows what's happened with Ozzy
and stuff of that but clearly maybe
there's a break between him meeting Ozzy
and and then meeting marionette and mine
my hair first and he then they get
filled in but for all we know he doesn't
know too much we know he knows Batman's
Bruce Wayne Tom yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] dangerous yeah I mean he did
walk in a Wayne Manor and find the
[ __ ] bat cave in ten minutes so
that's pretty dangerous it is I suppose
but I guess he doesn't really know who
Batman is does he so he doesn't quite
know the you know veracity or the
heaviness of the situation but um yeah
that's pretty much how we end we end
with the you know the mosquito going
into the blue flame and which I didn't
like it should have been a moth yeah
should have been a mark yeah I agree
my girl's good with that yeah and we get
we get a quote from Lin Zhi Zhu on I've
definitely said that incorrectly the
miracle is not to walk on water the
miracle is to walk on earth what what
does that mean death it means like a
light you just it's a miracle that
you're alive when you walking around
surviving right right right I think I
don't know I think I think what Jones
has done is she's just googled something
I couldn't oh yeah I believe so because
I just googled Lin Zhi Ling Zhi yuan and
it it reveals a Wikipedia page written
in I think it's Cyrillic I think it's
Russian okay and he looks like a monk
from the eighth eighth hundreds so yeah
there you go again it's not like more
where he's quoting pop songs and novels
and they all mean something but they're
all really clever and Moore's just gone
on wikiquote and it's just typed in walk
up war and and you know seen what people
have said and that's pretty much how it
ends really a small incident
I can't mosquito going into the ether
which you know could be parallels
perhaps for our heroes heading into the
inevitable path of dr. Manhattan but
just before we get on to the PostScript
the few letters what's your feelings all
together on the issue definite um it's
the best issue at the bunch yeah I
always say by Episode four you can tell
if you're into something and I'm so so
on it it's getting better and it's very
slow and it doesn't feel like it's going
anywhere and you like no it needs to
actually get to the plot soon or I lose
interest because I've got no idea what
anyone in this book is even up to a
swear God if they have like dr.
Manhattan fight Superman but at the end
they realized there's a bigger threat
and they've got a team up together and
take it down a go [ __ ] mental Tom I
will I will go [ __ ] mental I think
that I think I think that's fair it's
just it's showing that's what's gonna
happen I think that is what's gonna
happen and it's so it's so frustrating
because it's like this is not this in
this book that was supposed to be on a
12-month cycle is now aids earliest he's
gonna take 21 months to complete
yeah because they cope they go bimonthly
and you know I'm the sort of person that
I thought they were finishing it by 2019
maybe yeah hopefully but so it is
definitely bimonthly yo oh yeah yeah
it's gonna be it's from now on it's
gonna be every two months there's gonna
be a seat then I shouldn't they
shouldn't force the universe is to kind
of fit two timelines that pecan stick to
know that there look basically Frank
Miller
cannot stick to a [ __ ] deadline right
at all and they used to tie him in with
the main stuff but then they realized oh
[ __ ] Frank Miller he doesn't stick to a
[ __ ] deadline so they just give him
his own universe and they go oh yeah
Frank just release it in form when it's
time just just as long as you're working
on it yeah that's fine what else are you
up to what do you mean you make an every
female character a prostitute and so
yeah it's I really don't know why they
do it they don't need to and it's gonna
hold up the DC Universe yep the most
successful comic
like knock the market leader is now
getting held up its got like over a
hundred books however it's getting held
up because of one book you're right
you're right I'm stupid because I mean
the whole button rebirth stuff you know
it's implicit isn't it the whole the
whole watchman aesthetic and yeah we've
said this before like I don't know about
the modern comic book industry alms for
big fan of graphic novels and I'm a big
fan of graphic novels trade paperbacks
hardbacks I don't really read issues
monthly other than this to be honest I
don't understand why Jon's
dad just written the whole thing and
they could just do it as a one-year
event it's a bit of a shame I would love
to have a hardback book that he's just
Doomsday Clock and we could just go
through it it's a bit frustrating to be
honest of you yeah I get what's going on
because it's like we started these free
months ago and I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna reread you I'm an idiot so it's
like you know I it's tough but
nonetheless I think John Jones is CEO of
DC Comics as well so he's got lots of
[ __ ] on his plate and he's but it's
probably becoming a chore yeah I
recently did a Dark Knight master race
read through make sure you check it out
on my youtube channel everyone and I
basically I got halfway through it and
realized like the audio and the video
was pretty [ __ ] and I promised like I
was halfway through it and I had go back
and re-edit everything rerecord the
audio and I just thought it's not it's
not even worth it I'm not even
interested in this anymore I've got so
much other stuff I could be doing
entries became a chore but the videos
great guys think it's got about 200
views and we end up the issue with some
post for it material as I say pretty
much just letters from Byron to his
sister asking for various things it
doesn't really tell you too much about
the story it's cause I didn't read it
Jen you didn't read it kind of hard to
read as well like it's quite small you
got to sort of zoom in and you know we
you learn how long he's been in there so
the first letter we seize from 1962 we
get a letter from 1974 the final letters
from a
five get one 492 as well when he sort of
breaking out which I guess sort of puts
to the timeline of when Reggie and by
room together has been quite a few years
like you know training for a long time
so maybe Byron will come up later or
maybe they'll be some sort of you know
maybe he'll mention Byron to Manhattan
or someone like this and there's a few
nice touches we see like tears on the
letters as well and I think I think it's
put together well and there's a bit
where he's asking his sister for you
know 18 foot of three-point eight
millimeter aluminium alloy tubing and
cable cutters and one pair of goggles
and but it's you know it's not like
under the hood by Hollis Mason it
doesn't really flesh out the world we
get his obituary in there as well um and
you know how does it say you died and
it's a bitter eat ah it's um let's have
a look here walking in the fire yeah
yeah it just says death by entrance I
fingers why it says yeah my my laptops
just froze unfortunately here just as I
was about to look at it but yeah I
pretty much just says what you were
saying it doesn't she's cut off at the
bottom so you can't really see exactly
what you're speaking about but um in
terms of what we're speaking about
please gasp I should say watching The
Watchmen pod at gmail.com and watching
and watching pod on Twitter as well be
great to hear from you on there we don't
use a Twitter too often but the
Twitter's there but let us know what you
thought about this issue also comment
below and give us your feedback because
I have a comment from Joshua cool
actually Tom that's he says maybe Batman
is playing it like this guys and stable
let's put this guy away while I try to
figure this out on my own okay for
second kindness he means thanks for
thanks for commenting Josh but you're
wrong because Alfred said you're wrong
don't ever comment our videos again and
you know thank you very much
these are these are big this is a big
deal in the comic book world probably
one of the biggest deals where in our
Doomsday Clock and I think pound for
pound me and deaf are doing the longest
critical analysis out there and I've
listened to a lot of them you know
there's some guy from Texas doing ten
minutes and he's holding up the issue in
front of the camera but you know we go
deep people so please go deep in return
pause
and you know give us your long-form
criticism of this stuff
subscribe to definitions channel as well
that we're on and you know death we got
to mention you went pretty much viral
the other week you got like two hundred
files of views on a vid yeah it was
really weird my just today I watched a
Netflix movie and thought that's quite
interesting I'll do an end and explained
video on it not realizing that no one
else had done it and it was also a
foreign film as well and so yeah just
made one it's done really well I'm quite
happy with it but it's also sort of
cursed me into thinking that every
single video I do now Scott B that yeah
but you can't recapture lightning in a
bottle Tom but I probably still keep
making all these foreign film but ending
explains yeah
staying up till 4:00 in the morning just
like please please get a thousand views
you know or a point people in the
direction of all are watching reviews
within seven so far as obviously the
fourth Doomsday Clock we've done Killing
Joke and we interview John Higgins as
well which I still don't believe we did
which is definitely one of the best
things I've ever done in podcasting wise
you know it was it was so cool to talk
to the original colorist of Watchmen as
well so yeah go listen about everyone
because it was a great interview and the
guy was really insightful and it's
definitely worth your time especially if
you love comic books and you kind of
want to learn about the craft and how
colorings developed over the years and
evolved it was a really really good
interview and we're really lucky again
I'm on the show this baby I didn't think
we'd actually be able to get yeah and so
it was great to have a month it was it
was wonderful to have him on and I'm
sure if people listen they've checked it
out but it's on the podcast feed as well
please subscribe to the podcast if you
listen to this on YouTube you know
subscribe to deaf stuff as I say as well
we will be back
I sank to death before when on air we
need to finish Watchmen
you know we've got like five issues left
I think so we've broken the back of it
as it were and we're gonna try and get
them out a bit more rapidly any any
final thoughts death yeah don't read
Avengers first Thanos I tell you what
Tom I was getting hyped for I was hyped
for infinity war
coming out right and I thought I'm gonna
um your website I'm gonna start
reviewing some infinity war tie-ins
anyway I got this book calling Infinity
Gauntlet I like to read my stuff
chronologically and review it in that
order um
and I opened it and had this map in the
front of it like oh you are here you
need to read these seven other books
before anyway I went back and picked up
the first one Avengers first Thanos
[ __ ] hell it's absolutely massive it's
about 700 pages long and it's [ __ ] me
Tom it's a [ __ ] it's an infinite each or
not an infinity war it's a infinity ball
you know I mean it's literally nothing
but 70s 70s like ah dis comics I finally
stopped you Captain Marvel and he's like
but you didn't expect me to do this I
know you have thwarted me yes yeah
honestly Tom it's [ __ ] massive
and I don't know how I'm gonna get
through it yeah I just found out Amazon
yeah I'm looking at the back cover
oh yeah man from 1968 Captain Marvel ma
you know daredevil from 64 oh god yes
yes these Marvel I mean as a Kitsch sort
of ironic thing but ya know I mean fair
play fair play I respect that have you
seen Justice League yet cuz that came
out actually I'm off that soon yeah I
need to watch that it's fine I've
actually watched it about 30 times now
yeah well welcome home Tom you know I
mean I've got a film you days and I've
started like it's got the point now
where I'm just noticing every single
problem with it like the the one thing I
know it's today and Batman fights a
criminal on the roof at the start and
he's clean-shaven and then the next
scene he's got a full-on beard it's just
little things it's just stupid over
analyzing things you know I mean anyway
back to this comic book that will
completely overanalyzing ruined because
of it you know none of us can stand to
read anymore well we will be back in
like two months in May to tackle dooms
now we're doing Watchmen Tom oh yeah
yeah I mean I mean yeah subscribe
in terms of the in terms of doomsday
chronology we'll be back in May but yeah
in terms of the Watchmen stuff we'll be
back soon
maybe we'll tackle something else or
like I really want us to review all-star
Superman because I think it's incredible
but it's like there's so many reviews of
it it's like there's no real need but
you know if one person emails in and
says do it maybe we'll do it
I was thinking recently I was thinking I
said it's my friend the die finished a
third issue the second issue where clock
gives Louis his powers for the day yeah
that really that might be my single
favorite issue of a comic like I really
I think it's unbelievably good I'll read
it the other day and it's just yeah it's
just perfect it's just 26 pages of
perfection yeah it's really really I
didn't actually like it the first time I
read it and because I was expecting like
loads of fights and stuff right but then
I went back and reread it and was like
yeah this is really good so we're
probably I mean we are definitely gonna
carry on this podcast after Watchmen
yeah yeah I think as long as they don't
release like a doomsday sequel no no god
but sort of tied into everything if it's
even got like a watchman character and
it was so tied in a review unit now well
it's like we finish what you're gonna do
is a clock we've still got the four
Watchmen we still got the Watchmen film
we've got the Watchmen TV show that
isn't out at the time of us recording
this I'm probably gonna buy the Watchmen
role-playing game just cuz it's the only
thing that more oh I'm Watchmen over
than Watchmen now I just want to read it
so you know maybe we'll go through that
as well but yeah get in touch with us on
the email or tweet us you know let us
know what you thought about it have we
got any sponsors or anyone who's wants
to sponsor us Tom no we don't have any
sponsors yeah what the hell do you mean
every podcast has got to get you pull
your buddy finger on the alien episode
of great Sherlock so ever shoutouts loop
box sponsored by loot box there's a
month you get a free piece of [ __ ] that
you're gonna look and you'd put on a
shelf and never look at again she had
great greatest movie ever podcast base
of wars a believable podcast the latest
issue the latest episode is
was perfection really and I'm gonna be
on the podcast soon actually so yeah
you're not gonna get rid of me on the
definition channel but um death has
always it's been a pleasure bro thanks
so much yeah thank you and it's a good
night from me it's a good night from
Queen yes
you